[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: Good
morning, everybody.
Hi, I'm Ellie Powers.
And I'm a product manager
here on the Google Play team.
We have so many
different announcements
about what's new for all of you
app developers on Google Play
that we had to
create one session
with a whole bunch of people to
take you through all of them.
But before we get
into that, I want
to take a couple
minutes to talk to you
more about why I'm really
excited to work on Google Play.
I've been on the team
for about 4 1/2 years.
And one of the things that
really gets me excited
even now is really
meeting each of you
and hearing your stories.
For every app and game
on the Google Play Store,
there's a real story behind it.
You know, I love hearing
how did you come up
with that idea for
that new app or game.
What's really special
about it to you?
And I love trying out
all the different apps
and seeing how they work.
And I love hearing
about what happens
after you launch
your app, how it's
helping you build
a business, and how
you're using that app to really
transform people's lives.
So before we see what's
new in Google Play,
we're going to see
a video and take
a look at some of your stories.
Let's play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-I started running
in marathons to raise
money for Parkinson's research
in honor of my grandfather.
I always had this idea that
if I could get enough people
together, then
collectively, we would
have the clout of a
celebrity and then
companies would
want to sponsor us.
Being on the Android platform
has enabled us to reach people
all over the world.
They can help raise money
for our charity partners.
And it's helped make our
movement a global one.
-It's really cool
to take your hobby
and put it into
your full-time job.
Talk is an Android
app that allows
you to see all the
sensors on your vehicle
and to look at the fault codes.
From the way that it's happened
on the Google Play Store,
I've touched over a million
people with the app.
The community has
dragged me along with it
and told me what the want.
I've done that for them.
I'm very grateful
for where I am now.
And it's staggering
to see that something
I've written from
my garden shed is
liked by that many
people across the planet.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-We started right
after university.
It was myself, my
husband, and his brother.
Making games was
our childhood dream.
And this is what
we wanted to do.
Since we released Cooking Fever
on Android, it totally clicked.
We realized that
this is the way to go
and this is the
platform of the future.
We had millions of downloads
within the first months.
When we started, it
was just three of us.
And now, we're a company of
over 100 people making games
that we decide we want to make.
This has been a very
successful dream.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: I really
love watching this video
because it really
shares the diversity
of different developers that
we have here in the Android
and Google Play community.
So now, let's get on with what's
new on Google Play this year.
Here at Google, we found that
we build the best products when
we're able to launch and
iterate our products using
user feedback.
Products like Gmail, Chrome,
Maps, and Google Search
are all great examples of how
we've been able to do this.
And we want app
developers like you to be
able to do the same things.
So Google Play has been giving
all of you the biggest user
base, right, access to a
very wide range of people
all around the world.
But now, it's also
become the best place
to optimize your apps,
to take on user feedback,
and to measure how
your app is doing,
and to make those little tweaks
to make your app truly great.
So I mentioned that I
brought a big team of people
to help me deliver
these announcements.
So lightning talk style, we're
going to bring each of them
on to share something new
on Google Play with you.
And with that, I'd like to
bring out our engineering
director, Miles Barr.
[APPLAUSE]
MILES BARR: Hi, I'm Miles Barr.
I'm here today to talk to you
about the pre-launch report.
It's an exciting new feature
that we launched at Google I/O
this year.
The pre-launch report is built
on the Firebase Test Lab.
The Firebase Test Lab
is our data center
of real Android devices
where you can test your app.
It allows you to test your app
across a variety of devices,
Android OS versions,
and languages.
It's already performed
over one million tests
for developers like you.
You can run your
own custom tests
straight from Android Studio
or from the Firebase console.
Beta testing has always
been one most popular
and powerful features.
But we wanted to make it
even better by performing
a comprehensive set of tests on
your app before it goes live.
You can now opt in to
generating a pre-launch report
for every APK you upload to
the alpha and beta channels
in Google Play.
Releasing a new version of your
app can be an exciting time.
But you want to make sure
everything goes right.
After about an hour, you'll get
a report summarizing any issues
we found when testing your app.
The first thing we look at
is the stability of your app.
We use the Firebase Test Lab to
run your app on real devices,
telling you on which devices
your app crashed on start-up,
or if it crashes after a
deeper crawl of the app.
This means it won't be your
users finding the crashes
and giving you one star reviews.
We also show you
what your app looks
like on these different devices.
You get to see how it looks
like in different screen
resolutions, Android OS
versions, and languages.
This allows you to spot any
problems such as overflowing
text in your translations before
your app goes live allowing you
to fix them quickly and easily.
The final part of the report
highlights any security
vulnerabilities we find.
This includes any versions
of third party libraries
with known vulnerabilities, or
if you've accidentally followed
any security ante-patterns.
Previously, this information
was only available
after your app had gone live.
The pre-launch report brings
all this information together,
telling you about
these potential issues,
allowing you to fix them before
your app goes to production,
ensuring that you
and Google Play
give your users the best
experience possible.
Now, I'd like to bring on
stage Kobi Glick, product
manager for Google Play.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KOBI GLICK: Thanks, Miles.
Hi.
I want to talk to you
about beta testing.
Beta testing is the most popular
feature on the Google Play
Developer Console.
60% of the top 1,000
apps on Google Play
are running a beta
test right now.
And users notice it.
Apps that run a beta test
have higher rating on average.
Last year, we made it easier
for users to discover and join
beta programs.
With Open Beta, it's as
simple as clicking the URL.
We know that you love
and use beta testing.
And we often get
developer feedback,
like the one you
see from Pocket,
telling us how
beta testing helps
them connect to their users,
get feedback on new ideas,
and make sure the app is
ready to go to production.
To make it even easier for
users to discover and join
beta programs, we will allow
users to join them directly
from your Store listing
page on Google Play.
This will help you grow
larger beta programs
and connect to more testers.
Now, once you have
beta testers, you
want to get their
feedback, right?
You used to get the feedback
from various sources
and had two parse a
lot of information.
We will allow users to
give you private feedback
directly from Google Play.
This feedback is private.
It goes only to you.
And you can see it in the
Google Play Developer Console.
"Private" means other
users don't get to see it.
And it doesn't impact
your app star rating.
Now, we believe that apps should
run an Open Beta test even
before they go to production.
This is why we're introducing
a new section called
Early Access on Google Play.
This section will feature
exciting apps and games
that are still in development,
are running a beta test,
and haven't launched
to production yet.
This will allow early adopters
and influencers to discover
those apps, try them out, and
give you valuable feedback,
helping you find product
market feet earlier,
and fine tune your game's KPI's.
In our first collection,
we have 28 apps and games,
as you can see here, with
some pretty cool titles.
For example, Read Feed, an
Android first online book club,
or Eva.
The founder, whose parents
and sisters are deaf,
created this app to help
deaf people and people
with hearing disabilities
to participate in real life
conversations.
We have LEGO, the kids
and family power brand
with their first ever
in-house mobile game.
It's a 3D LEGO set you can
touch, twist, and build,
just like the brick sets
we all grew up with.
This is not just for
free-to-play tiles.
Never Alone, a gorgeous game
developed E-Line Media, who
researched together
with the Alaska natives,
is coming to Google Play on
Early Access as a premium
title.
We are sure that those
changes that we're
making to beta testing will
help you grow even bigger
beta programs, get
feedback from users,
and make your apps and
games even more awesome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'd like to invite Wei
Chai, an engineering
manager on Google Play.
[APPLAUSE]
WEI CHAI: Thank you.
Hi.
I'm here to talk about
some new features
for Play apps discovery.
Google Play is the
primary destination
for discovering apps
and games on Android.
Today, we provide
various ways in the Store
to assist users in
finding new apps
and to drive developer outcomes
by helping you get discovered.
Recently, we've been
developing and experimenting
with a new way for users to
find new apps, contextual app
discovery.
It targets underlying needs
that drive when and why you
might need new apps.
These needs could be the
ones in our everyday lives,
such as you learn something
new, plan a vacation,
or eat at a home.
Our user studies show that
most users look for new apps
at the time they need them.
Therefore, we want to
explicitly target the needs
by building contextual
collections of apps
so that users can find
complementary apps needed
at the same time.
It also makes it
easier for users
to find apps or types of
apps they may not have
heard of before coming to Play.
For example, imagine a user
is searching for a wallpaper.
We might recognize that the
user is interested in a broader
need, personalize my phone,
and show complementary apps,
including not only wallpapers,
but also personalizable ,
keyboards themes, and ringtones.
Let's take a look
at how it works.
We identify the
underlying needs based
on users' searches, views,
context, and interests
and show complementary apps
around the need on search
result pages, app install
pages, or homepages,
where it makes sense to do so.
So another example,
if the user is on app
install page for Trulia, maybe
he or she is buying a house.
And then we'll show
great other apps
for finding houses for sale,
calculating your mortgage,
and doing interior design.
If a user is traveling
to San Francisco,
we might anticipate
the user's needs
for apps for the upcoming
trip and show a collection
of relevant apps for exploring
San Francisco on the user's
homepage.
To further demonstrate the idea,
if you look at your Play Store
homepage now, for
some of you, based
on your interest
and the context,
we're showing a
collection of apps
called Best of
Google I/O, where you
can find nominees of this
year's Google Play awards.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, I would like to
continue was Fergus product
manager at Google Play.
FERGUS HURLEY: Thanks, Wei.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everyone.
My name is Fergus Hurley.
I'm product manager
on Google Play.
I'm here to talk to
you about reviews.
So building on top of
the phenomenal engagement
that developers have had
with the reply to reviews
functionality, we've made
a lot of enhancements
to the ratings and
views functionality
on Play over the
last few months.
We've added being able to see
your ratings over time, being
able to see ratings breakdown
across country, language,
device, be able
to see the device
metadata for each
individual review
so you can be able
to understand what
was the RAM of that
user on that device,
and even be able to search
within all the reviews.
We've also enabled you
to now be able to now get
an email notification when
a user updates their review
after you've responded.
We also added Highlights.
These are snippets
that users see
when they come to your app
listing page on the Play Store.
And they can be
able to see these
to be able to make
their purchase decision.
You'll be able to see them
into Play Developer Console.
And you can be
able to figure out
which ones are the ones you
want to be able to invest in
more and be able to respond to
the reviews that are happening
in those Highlights.
This year at I/O, we
announced reviews analysis.
This includes two parts.
The first part is Topics.
Topics are unique words that are
relevant to your application.
And we surface them.
For example, for this
language learning app,
"Klingon" is the topic.
And you can see that there's
the average effect on rating
of each one these and the
volume distribution for each
of these topics.
We even tell you what is the
effect that each one of these
is having on your overall
rating in the Play Store.
The next part of the reviews
analysis is Benchmarks.
Benchmarks shows you what are
the common topics that people
talk about your application and
nearly all other applications
on the Play Store.
You can be able to see design,
stability, resource usage.
And then you can
be able to see how
you compare to the other apps
in your category in the Play
Store.
We also show you
what is the effect
that each one of
these common topics
is having on your
rating in the Play Store
so you can be able to
prioritize your investment
of your resources and even
have your team be able to go in
and be able to read all
the reviews about design.
For now, reviews analysis works
for English only and only when
you have a certain
number of reviews that
fall within these categories.
So when we have all these
reviews on the Play Store
and we have this
ability to be able to do
reviews analysis
on all the reviews,
we said, let's have a
look at all the reviews
and see what are the
common topics that
are impacting one-star and
five-star reviews to help
developers be able to
prioritize their investments
and be able to find out how to
get a higher rating on Play.
What we found is that across
all the one-star reviews that
have a common topic,
50% are about stability.
So really investing in building
a high quality app that does
not crash is really important.
We also found that
for when you want
to get your app
to a five-star app
and you fix the
stability issues,
really investing in design,
performance, and usability,
and speed of your application
is really, really important
because that results in 65%
of the five-star reviews.
We also launched at I/O
this year the reviews API.
This enables you to
be able to respond
to your reviews
on the Play Store
with whatever workflow
you use yourself to be
able to do custom support.
We partnered with zendesk and
conversocial on this launch.
And you can be able to
use those tools today
to be able to start responding
to your Play Store reviews.
I'm now going to hand over
to Riccardo Govoni, who's
the engineering manager on Play.
[APPLAUSE]
RICCARDO GOVONI: Hello.
So today, I'm here
to give you tips
on how you can better
understand who your users are
and where they come from.
You're probably familiar with
the use of acquisition reports
that we launched in the Play
Developer Console last year.
It tells you how many
Store listing visitors
installed your app and
converted into buyers.
And it does so by breaking
the information down
by acquisition channel.
So you know how many people
discovered your app organically
in the Play Store versus
coming from different channels
like your website or
AdWords campaigns.
Over the past year, we
received great feedback
about this feature, like
this one from Trulia.
And it helped many developers
like you optimize your business
in Play.
So you'll be happy to
hear that we recently
announced a new feature, being
able to measure your user
acquisition performance
at the country level.
And this is great
when you're entering
new markets, like emerging
ones, like Brazil or India,
and really optimize your app
experience for all your users
across the world.
But optimizing your business
performance in isolation
is not really that helpful.
How do you know,
for example, if you
look at your organic
conversion rate,
if it is as good as it could be,
if you're leaving opportunities
on the table?
So right now, it's
not that easy.
But we're about to
make it a lot better.
So soon, we will be launching
another great feature,
benchmarks against
your peers, so you
will be able to compare how your
Store listing commercial rate
fares against similar
apps in your category.
First, we'll provide
an overall benchmark
about your organic user
acquisition performance.
And this will give you an
indication on how your store
listing is performing globally.
But more, you will be also
able to measure your user
acquisition performance
at the country
level against the
benchmark at that level.
For example, here, you
can see that our app is
getting some traction in Korea.
But at 24%, we are lagging
behind the benchmark.
This is a moment
where maybe you want
to review the quality of your
Store listing translations
or consider localizing
your assets.
We'll also give
you an indication
on how you're progressing
against the benchmark.
So you know if you still
have room for improvement
or if you're really among
the best and aim for the top.
And when you're
ready to take action,
Play Developer
Console has plenty
of features to help you
optimize your Store listing
performance and your
original success,
such as Store listing
experiments or app translation
services.
And we'll offer
recommendation about those
right next to the benchmarking
results when relevant.
So this everything I have
in Store for you today.
I believe that with country
breakdowns and benchmarks,
you will be able to even better
optimize your business in Play.
Benchmarks are going to roll
out over the next few weeks.
Country breakdowns
is already there.
Go give it a try.
And now, I'd like to introduce
on stage Mona Vajolahi, product
manager on Play.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MONA VAJOLAHI: Thanks, Riccardo.
I'm here to talk
about what we are
doing in Google Play for
that next billion users.
Android is growing really
fast in emerging markets.
By 2018, we expect 1.2
billion new Android users
to come online in
emerging markets.
In Google Play, we've
been working really hard
to make sure those users have
a great experience, especially
given some of the infrastructure
challenges in those markets.
One key pillar is to have
a product and an ecosystem
of apps that work well
on slow connections
and on low end devices.
Our user studies have
shown over and over again
that connectivity and data
challenges affect all users
in emerging markets,
regardless of where they leave
or how much money they make.
Connectivity challenges
are here to stay.
By 2020, still 300
million users in India
will be on connection times
that are equivalent of 2G.
And even when
Wi-Fi is available,
it is often patchy
and unreliable.
So one of the key areas of
focus for us in Google Play
has been to build an experience
that is fast, lightweight,
and reliable, where every user,
regardless of their connection
time, can find and download
apps that meet their needs.
Over the past year,
we have optimized
the performance of
the Play Store app
and made it much faster on 2G.
We have also reduced
the amount of data
used by the Store itself
and for key activities
like downloading apps
and updating apps.
These changes have brought
more users to the Store.
They visit the store more often.
And they download more apps.
We also know that our users
everywhere, especially
in emerging markets, want
a Store experience that
reflects their local interests
and the needs of their country
and their region.
We've been working closely
with local developers
in markets like India
and Brazil to make
sure those apps reach their
local audience in the Store.
In addition, we have been
supercharging our editorial
content in the Store
to make sure users
are able to easily find
locally relevant apps that
meet the needs of
different segments of users
in the market.
And with that, I'd
like to bring up
to stage Kunal Soni, who is the
head of apps and games business
development in Southeast Asia.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KUNAL SONI: Thanks, Mona.
Hi, everyone.
I'm here to talk to you
about creating great quality
apps that'll work effectively,
not just for smartphone users
today, but also for
the next billion users
as they get connected
in the years to come.
We're seeing incredible
momentum in emerging markets
all around the world.
They're expected to account for
80% of total smartphone growth
globally.
In order to be relevant and
successful in these markets,
it's important for us
to design the right app
experience aimed at solving
three important challenges.
Firstly, while 4G and LTE and
other network technologies
will grow fast, there will still
be one billion mobile internet
users in 2020 who will be on 2G.
That's a sizable segment for you
to think about and solve for.
Secondly, mobile data
speeds vary a lot
across markets requiring
you to tailor the app
experience accordingly.
And finally, data is expensive
relative to income levels
in several markets.
And therefore,
helping your users
manage their data cost should
be an important priority.
In order to help you
tackle these challenges
and support your
growth, we've identified
a set of tools
and best practices
that we believe can help you.
This is what is
called the Building
for Billions Framework,
focused on three
important areas, connectivity,
device compatibility, and data
cost.
By the way, what
I'm covering here
is by no means limited
to emerging markets.
These principles will apply
equally well across the world.
Let's start by looking
at connectivity.
In order to optimize for
unreliable or intermittent
connectivity, ensure
that your app prioritizes
bandwidth requests, fetching
text before rich media or data.
Ensure that you offer a
great offline experience
so that all your
users can interact
with the app at all times,
regardless of connectivity
using cached data.
Let's talk about devices.
Many devices in emerging markets
have smaller, lower resolution
screens.
In order to ensure a seamless
user experience across devices,
use density independent pixels
while defining app layouts.
Ensure that your graphics
and text work well
on low and medium
density screens.
And adjust your memory
footprint dynamically
to ensure compatibility across
devices with different RAM
configurations.
Finally, let's talk
about data cost.
The first cost your
users will incur
will be related to the cost
of installation of your app.
And therefore, it's important
to keep a tight focus
on reducing the
APK size, ideally
well below 10 megabytes.
In order to accomplish
this, you should
reduce the number
and size of images
within the APK using tools
like WebP and scalable vector
graphics or SVG.
You can shrink the code
size of your APK using tools
like Proguard, which
remove unused code.
And finally, you can
consider Multi-APK
as an option to create
APK's split by density
so that users target
the right version
of the app that specifically
targets their device density.
With that, we come to
the end of my session.
If you're interested
to know more,
do join us for the session
on Building for Billions
in Android, today at 3:00 PM.
Next, I'd like to invite
Milena Nikolic, engineering
manager on Google Play.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MILENA NIKOLIC: Thank you.
Thanks, Kunal.
Hi, I'm Milena, engineering
manager on Google Play.
I'm here to talk to you
about Play Console app.
Yes, we have finally launched
an Android app for Google Play
Developer Console.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you.
We have to admit that
it took us a while.
It took us much longer
than it took you guys.
But we've made it.
And we can tell you this
app stuff is pretty sweet.
We really like it now.
Our new app can help you follow
the performance of your app
on Google Play and do time
critical actions on the go.
When you're rapidly
iterating, you
need a powerful tool that's
in your pocket all the time.
And we've built Play Console
app exactly with those use cases
in mind.
Whether you're looking to
quickly reply to user review
or to show off the
performance of your app
when running to a
meeting, Play Console app
should be there to support you.
Regarding an
initial feature set,
obviously, you can check
installs and uninstalls
of your app and you
can break them down
based on a number of
different dimensions,
including country, device,
app version, and much more.
In addition to that,
you can check out
crash reports, including hourly
data and full stack traces.
You can also follow your
app's ratings and reviews.
And you can reply to reviews.
You can also follow the
state of your release
as it moves from beta
through stage rollout,
all the way to
production and much more.
Oh, also, you can get
push notifications
when something important
happens with your app,
for example, when your
app update goes live.
App is now available
on Google Play.
In the last 24 hours
since we launched it,
more than 10,000 developers
installed it and rated it
at 4.85 stars on average.
If you're not among
those 10,000 developers,
please, please go
and install it.
We think you'll
find it very useful.
Also, we are very keen
to hear your feedback.
So please send us an easy
feedback that you have.
We plan to work on it.
We plan to add much
more functionality
in the next couple of versions.
And if you're still
not convinced,
please do come visit us in the
Play Sandbox, where you can
see it in action for yourself.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Next, I would like to invite
Suresh Ganapathy and Shobana
Ravi.
[APPLAUSE]
SURESH GANAPATHY:
Thanks, Milena.
So we showed you a sneak
preview of Android Instant
Apps at the keynote yesterday.
Today, I want to tell
you a little bit more
about how to build
Android Instant
Apps and the new opportunities
that this could open up.
First, let's do a quick recap
of the announcement yesterday,
for those of you
who weren't around.
So Android Instant Apps
lets you access apps
by simply tapping on
links, even if you
don't have the app installed.
As a developer, this means
that this is just an upgrade
to your existing Android app.
This is not a new, separate app.
It's compatible with
Android Jelly Bean and up
and will reach over
a billion users.
Now, we understand that
this is a big change.
And we want to get it right.
So we're going to be
rolling this out gradually
to both users and developers
over the next year.
So let's talk about how
you'd upgrade your app
to run instantly.
As a developer, you
start by telling us
the links to your domain
that your app can open.
This is really easy to do
with Android App Links, which
we announced last year.
Next, if your app
is really big, you
may want to consider is
splitting it into modules.
This allows Google Play
to download only the parts
of the app that are
required on the fly when
the user taps on the link.
Next, we think
that users may have
slightly different
expectations of what an app can
do when it's running instantly.
So Instant Apps will not have
access to some capabilities,
like creating a
homescreen widget.
Finally, we're building
a whole new set
of features for
Instant Apps that we
want you to take advantage of.
My favorite is run
time permissions.
Android Instant Apps will
use run time permissions
going all the way
back to Jelly Bean.
Now, I want to talk a little
bit about some new opportunities
that Instant Apps could open up.
We've hacked together
a couple of fun demos
that I want to show
you as examples.
Can we switch to the
demo feed, please?
OK.
So Instant Apps lets you deliver
the same rich and immersive
experiences to both users
who have installed your app
and the ones who haven't.
So the demo here is-- my buddy
Jake created this really cool
photo sharing app.
It can capture panoramic
and display them
in a really unique way.
Now, he sent me a picture
that he captured with this app
when he was on a
trip to Machu Picchu.
I really want to see the
picture that he shared,
but I'm not quite sure if I
want to install the app as yet.
With Instant Apps,
this is not a problem.
All I have to do is tap a link.
With one tap, the app
opens up, instantly
deep linked right to the
panorama that Jake shared.
It even uses the
sensors on the phone
to pan the image as
Shobana moves the device.
Isn't that amazing?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
At the other end
of the spectrum,
Instant Apps also lets you
create very lightweight apps
that don't even have to
take the user out of context
to what they were doing.
Shobana and I recently made
plans to go to a concert.
So I booked my tickets.
It's a Shins concert.
And I sent her a message
asking her to book hers.
Now, she doesn't have the
ticketing app on her phone.
When he taps the link, the
app opens up instantly.
But it didn't open up
as a full-screen app.
It opened up just as a dialogue.
It has all the information
she needs pre-filled.
Her seats are
right next to mine.
And with Android Pay,
it's one tap to pay,
all of this while
of the Hangouts app
is still in the background.
[CHEERING]
Shobana-- thank you.
Shobana didn't have to leave
her conversation with me
to buy these tickets.
This can be really
interesting if you
want to help the user
complete a simple task
with as little
friction as possible.
So those are the two examples
that we have for you today.
Can we switch back please?
Can we switch back
to the slides?
We'll be just a moment.
Perfect.
I wanted you to see the
URL so you can learn more.
So if you go g.co forward
slash Instant Apps,
you can learn more.
There is a sign-up
form if you're
interested in upgrading
your app to run instantly.
With that, I'd like to
introduce Purnima Kochikar, who
leads Play's global business
development team, on stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
Thank you, Suresh.
How many think that
Instant Apps are amazing?
[APPLAUSE]
You know, I have
been so excited.
I was in a Uber this morning
and it was on the radio.
And I was, like,
thrilled to bits.
Good morning, everyone.
I am Purnima Kochikar.
And I work for you.
My team and I have
the great privilege
to work with each
and every one of you
to help you build successful
businesses on Google Play.
Android powers
increasingly new screens
across new markets, empowering
people across the world.
And it is this scale that allows
Google Play to provide you
the largest app distribution
platform in the world.
Let's look at some numbers.
In 2015, one billion
monthly active users
across 190 countries
drove 65 billion installs
on Google Play.
[APPLAUSE]
Mind boggling, isn't it?
In 2015, the number
of game developers
who had a game with more
than one million installs
grew by over 50%, which
means more people are
being successful.
And if you look back and you
say, OK, that is installs.
There is more installs per game.
But are we making money?
In 2015, the average
spend-per-user across Play
grew by all over 30%
when compared to 2014.
So as you can see, we have a
very thriving community waiting
for the things that you create.
These are incredibly
impressive numbers.
But not of it would be
possible without you,
our developer community.
So where I sit on
a daily basis, we
see developers across
the world, big and small,
creating apps that change
lives and games that delight.
Each day, my team and I
are inspired and humbled
by how you are taking
your personal passions
and converting them into
successful businesses.
I hope the video
that Ellie shared
with you was as inspirational
to you as it is to us.
Over the last year, we
connected with one million
of you across various channels
to help you understand
and access the tools
we are building,
as well as to tell you what the
market opportunities that are
there in front of you.
You heard today, emerging
markets, new ways
to build your business,
all these tools really
help you build your business.
Now, here's the
interesting thing.
Each of those
instances we learned,
we figured out how to
improve our products.
So I hope you take the time
to visit us in the Sandbox
to tell us how we
can do things better.
And I'm also excited
to see what you
will do with the
new capabilities
that we have announced today.
We also use this
opportunity to get
you connected with each other.
How many of you are sitting with
people that you already know?
Should you be?
So I hope you take this
opportunity to really step out
and meet each other, understand
what everybody is doing.
There are people from
around the globe here today.
It is a unique opportunity.
And therefore, I am
extremely excited to announce
the very first Google Play
Awards this evening, 7:00 PM,
at Stage 7.
You can't forget that.
7:00 PM, at Stage 7.
So please come to see the
great apps and games that are
being showcased, get inspired.
Join us.
Thank you very much for coming.
And here's how you can
keep in touch with us.
We hope to see you this
evening at 7:00 PM.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]